joining us now with reaction House
Judiciary Committee ranking member
congressman Doug Collins who appoints
the senator replaced Johnny Isakson who
I've known for many years congressman
before I get to this that be the
governor of the state of Georgia he gets
that Big Sean yeah I'd like the governor
to appoint you because you have turned
into a rock star a Republican with a
backbone a Republican that you went out
there and you released transcripts that
no other congressman would release that
is the type of leadership we need in the
Senate I would urge the governor to
appoint you I think you'd do a great job
I hope that happens would you take it if
if offered yes Sean would we believe we
could offer great for the Georgia but
also be there for this president
continue to fight back with this you
know Democratic farce show has been all
year we believe we're well suited for
that and I appreciate your endorsement
there you have been a rising star
there's been a few voices that have
emerged in this madness you're
definitely one of them and I applaud
your courage let's talk more about what
we just heard here I've never seen a
president go through this the Democrats
have done nothing for the American
people in three years except hate this
president where does this go in your
opinion well it's now time for Jerry
Nadler to make chicken salad out of the
ship show we'll see how that works I
don't think it's going to happen because
what they'd have to do is take
presumption they would have to take
hearsay they would have to take nothing
of quid pro quo nothing that this
president did wrong and make it into
some viable articles of impeachment to
show the American People that he's done
something wrong but you know how I know
they don't really have anything because
its first hearing next week is Sean is
it gonna bring academics in to tell us
what an impeachable offense is I'll tell
you what an impeachable offense is not
it's everything we've seen from Adam
Schiff and the Democrats for the past
year is they've attacked a very
successful president who is simply doing
the best job he can for America and
that's what we're going to start next
week get ready I've said this before
judiciary show the lights are gonna come
on get the popcorn ready because it's
now time to actually get down to
business to show what this shift show
has actually looked like in person you
like I know some people maybe they don't
like the president's style cuz he fights
but he fought to get the biggest tax
cuts in history and get rid of more
bureaucracy than any president in the
last hundred years and he found a way to
get the border wall money
he he kept his promises on judges and
trade deals and look at the economy who
do you think gets it on the Democratic
side
and do you think Democrats are in a
panic are they telling you secretly
anything about how they really feel they
are I'm listening to the several
Democrats and I'm working one Democrats
across now here's something's very
interesting the hearing we're gonna have
next week I mean it's supposed to be the
first opportunity for the president to
actually be able to mount you know any
kind of defense as far as answering
questions but there's no reason for the
president's attorneys frankly to be a
part of acting academics what they
believe the Constitution says this is a
total abdication by Jerry Nadler who has
become basically a figurehead for Nancy
Pelosi and Adams chef to tell him what
to do and that's what's gonna happen
next week well we've got to have his
number one Adam Schiff has to testify
he's claimed to be a special counsel a
prosecutor like Ken Starr well if Ken
Starr can come before the committee and
actually take questions from everybody
then let's see if Adam Schiff can maybe
he can do a little better without the
gavel in his hand telling the truth and
being truthful with the American people
about what his involvement was in this
whole thing and also where he's going
with this plan but we also have members
on the committee who are coming
privately and saying if we don't make
this fair if we don't let the president
have a defense here if we just rammed
this through then the American people
are already seeing through it and Shawn
you already brought it up tonight we
have members who were who had the
audacity to say we should do something
other than impeachment on the Democratic
side get really I guess pressured into
submission to have say oh no I didn't
really mean the censure I think we got
to impeach him this is how sad they are
coming into Thanksgiving oh I had some
of the best years of my life living in
your state of Georgia maybe you don't
know this I was the emcee the night that
Newt Gingrich became the Speaker of the
House at his event
thank you for your fight you're out
there I hope Republicans are learning
from guys like you and Jim Jordan and
Turner and Nunez I can't met Ratcliffe
you guys have done a great job thank you